ee ahkah これはぽれはすごい buse 機 hus ちょっと今回ぽっち
等でウードゥ
もめりおんっ
[音楽]
多分こうれてないと思うよ実がなってるかわかんないんですけど今回こちらもベリー
よっていうものを買いましたいやー
これはやばいと思うのコレなにかといいますと
てずまずの精密機械です皆さんあの vr playstation vr とかで
意外と合わせられているかと思うんですけどスマートグラスってご存知ですか
スマートからそれは
[音楽]
すいませんちょっとわからないです何かだいたいそういう感じですよ明日まあから
グラフスマートフォンっていうのは電話機がスマートになったスマートフォンスマート
グラフっていうのは賢くなったベガねつまりぜひ内のメガネってございますやもう本当
に突発的に買っちゃったなんか広告見てたらたまたまスマートグラスっていうのが出て
きてあのメガネかけた瞬間もなんかで正解が変わるっていうかさーこの府県
ライドこの空間がなんか
開けますをしゃべっててわからないもんねどんなんだろうと中ずに思って買ってしまい
ましたね
う発行がもうめっちゃ頑丈ですもんうわーこれっとなんだろう今回はこんな感じなん
ですけどもそれだけてみましょう
今何か入ってるな
[音楽]
ただのメガネただのメガネですそんなことないよイヤホンも入ってます平安座充電器
継母
これは何だ
うわぁこっちだこっちが本物でしたどうぞ上げ幅山が入ってゆけでこちらが次世代の
スマートグラスでございますみたところで特に何も変でもないんですけども
なんかすごいですね中川特殊な加工になってるか
人生大が来た沿いをすごいてこれひょっとしたらなんか vr 恋分じゃねーか的な
まずホントちょっと使い方
は何もわからない本と戦っ系と思った勢いで買っちゃったっていう気持ちなんで
ちょっと正直わかんないところある
んもう完全や明治当社のこれこれ ipod nano がついてますねぷるーさせて
いいのかな
これ大丈夫品とふわっふわっをフレットえっとゾーンエプソンって書いてある
エペソでカジュアル見えますすかエプソンで書いてありますがここにエプソンが凄い
凄いなにこれなにこれ
ここで神コレ公園ぷっ web そんな芸タイプ村
えっもう全力だった皆さんに何か見えてないと思うんですけど完全にもベリー8日でも
ここであるんですよ
a 扱いオスで待って強い子以降はこれやばいは慰安をついてるんですよ
なんか汚いかきたよだきたすべてのアップ d を見るにはサークルをタップします
はい何がなるは間悩んでタッチできないとどうすればいいかこれで動かすってことなく
動いてるはここで何かボタンあるんだねこれをしてみようか
なんか動くぞひとまず族説明書よりましょうか
あ
あっはぁ動かせる動かせるきたトラックパッドでこれで何か10時って動かせます
ちょっと待っておれなんか名やわけねこれ問題はこれで何ができるかですあ
カメラた手が写ってるも自分の音と匂いだのしかいる中で視界が入ってる動画も撮れ
るって訳だよね
きた今動画になってますクエの動く方向で動画が撮れてるというほらカメラ
照明照明
ヒカキンさん所沢で思ってる汚い僕の部屋
こんな裏側まで全部見れるわけですよすごいですね
今僕はこの目の前で今ネット動いてますすげー
どうやって伝えればいいのかね方法を持ったんだかだけ伝えればいいんだろうかね
わからないですよねや申し訳ないけど僕の目の前ですか怒ってないんですよ俺遊び方は
基本的にはげながらネットをしたり歩きながら熱湯したアブナーそれ違うなと危ないん
ですがってやりましょうボーガー楽しんだり保存した映像を見たりスマートフォンの
映像を鈍器したり後アプリを使ってゲームとか出来るらしいです
ね今書道ってこれでエロ動画見たいとして3 d エロ動画なるんじゃないかいける
いちでしたこれまさか
3自然と見てるお
府は魚まま
わっエロ動画だ
はぁ
これはすごい
うわぁわぁわあ
これやばい